millions of people could have problems
flying later this year because of a
looming deadline for so-called real ID
documents at airports the US Travel
Association says get this as many as 182
million Americans may not have the right
driver's license or ID card to pass
through airport security now the
nation's airports want the Trump
administration to delay the October 1st
deadline requiring so-called Real ID
Kris Van Cleave is at Dwight D
Eisenhower Airport in Wichita Kansas
Chris good morning I think a lot of
people are thinking you know my ID looks
pretty real when I take it out of my
wallet so why our airports warning about
chaos well good morning airports really
want people to start paying attention to
this sign they know only about 3 in 10
Americans have a real ID and Congress is
getting worried too a number of
lawmakers sent a letter to DHS asking
what the contingency plan is so people
don't show up at an airport like this
one October 1st and learn they can't fly
it's the must-have for 2020 a Real ID
compliant form of identification
Stephen Reese is updating his driver's
license I just want to have it ready so
if I want to travel I can and we have a
son overseas that we want to go see and
visit the Real ID Act was passed in the
wake of 9/11 after several of the
hijackers improperly obtained state IDs
a compliant Real ID will be required
starting October 1st to board a plane
enter a federal building or a military
base but many states have been slow to
implement Oregon and Oklahoma won't
start issuing them until this summer
the potential is catastrophic Tori
Barnes from the US Travel Association
says 57% of Americans
really don't even know about the October
1st deadline we're absolutely not Real
ID ready at all we know 99 million
Americans don't have a real ID it's
gonna be Thanksgiving 2020 where grandma
goes to get on a plane and she can't go
see her grandkids that could cause chaos
at airports 80,000 people on the first
day could be turned away about half a
million in the first week and 300
million dollars is what that could cost
an economic loss these Real ID licenses
require extra documentation forcing some
to make multiple trips to the DMV
I ain't praying what it's supposed to
bring you'll need a valid ID passport or
birth certificate proof of your social
security number and date of birth plus
two items proving state residency you
have to have the go star TSA officers at
airports nationwide are now warning
fliers they won't be able to get to
their flights come October really unless
they update their IDs and states are
urging people to do it now we will be as
ready as we can
Richard Holcomb runs the Virginia DMV my
talk to officials like yourself and I
ask are you guys going to be ready for
this deadline is your state gonna be
ready for this deadline I kind of get an
answer but we hope so we're doing
everything we can you know we're a
little concerned about 1.8 million
Virginians coming into our offices
between now and October 1 so he's
deployed what he calls his secret weapon
for converted buses rolling through
Virginia up to four days a week they are
fully functioning mobile DMVs Jane
Standley got in without even waiting way
easier and shorter lines all right now
Congress is looking at a proposal to
make pre-check easier TSA PreCheck that
gets you expedited screening here work
as Real ID also your passport a Global
Entry card or a military ID will work
and I know nobody wants to go to the DMV
but the time is now guys do you have
your real ID no I love Kris when you
were talking to the official there and
you say your voice goes up a couple of
octaves that's never a good sign we're
working on it yeah we're a little
concerned that means they're very
concerned at least we're getting the
word out so that's good very much but a
lot of people still don't know Kris
thank you very much Wendy one of the
producers here hi Wendy what was
standing in line she had an appointment
and she said she had to wait two hours
yeah now you know I think the lines are
only going to get longer